the soul series is very much about
building your own stories and there are
a few things in particular down the pit
that allow you to tell your own tale so
I'm going to tell you a bit of a story
but while I tell it I want you to notice
how all the things I mentioned can be
interpreted in different ways so the pit
it's one of the people around here toss
all their rubbish Copsey so you'll know
what whatever they'd rather be rid of
the grave of Saints is inhabited by the
Rat King who commands a small army
inside the giant pit live the tiny
beings that were once man's friends
you've invaded the rat King's burrow and
he has good reason to distrust humans
long ago I struck an accord with a human
chieftain was agreed humans would rule
the lands lapped by the sun's rays and
rats all that was below but humans are
liars old schemers and cheats the time
came they broke their word and hunted us
down I had their word the underworld was
ours to rule untouched as it is by the
Rays of the Sun the more humans coveted
the more blinded they became as to what
truly mattered and that is why I pity
the fools called humans but you conquer
his burrow and he gives you the right to
serve you learned that rats have a very
very different view on the world with
different ideas about what's pure that's
for sure and as you prove yourself to
him you learn that they once had another
human amongst them take this ring it was
forged by a human who was once among us
the ferrous lock stone contraptions
around the place and the ring that was
forged make me think that the human
might have been Farris himself ferrous
the vagabond was a legend who wandered
the lands creating contraptions to help
those who were in dire and sincere need
the Rat King would have been one of
these people in need of defence from
humans and kind of in need of restoring
his own faith in humanity I like to
think that he built the
raps in the grave of saints to help the
Rat King and that he crafted the crest
of the rat for the Rat King to give to
humans for humans could activate the
traps to defend the Burrow and who knows
maybe eventually trust in humans could
be slowly repaired my servant well met
indeed would seem some sunlight poisoned
creatures are worthy of great honor the
host permitted me to dream one day rats
and humans may yet live and die together
in peace so where do we find furrows
well here's a perfect example of how the
story branches out let's look at this
skeleton here it's placed really honor
airily and it almost makes me think that
it could be pharaohs or perhaps it's a
man named Havel who is referred to in
the associated bonfire warp zone for
this area if it's even significant at
all then I personally lean towards it
being hvar since the bonfire refers to
him having a resting place here and you
can just see this skeleton from below as
you traverse this zone another reason I
like to think it might be hovel is
because I can imagine Ferris still being
further below speaking of names they
call this place the grave of saints and
I'd say that the red phantom of one
Saint can be found further down in new
game+ you are attacked by the red
phantom of a cleric who wears the exact
same armor as the fire keeper in Dark
Souls 1 down to the very blood-stained
skirt that she wears somebody told me
that de grève of a saint lies below here
not built by the king no no it did back
to our time long before him so in Dark
Souls 1 anestachio was a fire keeper
with the dingy set and both said
descriptions tell us that the smoke and
the ashes of the bonfires have darkened
them over the years Anastasia's skirt
was blood-stained
and I always took this to mean that law
Trek did this when he killed her but I
could be wrong on that and maybe the
blood stain has to do with the fact that
she was disfigured in some way for we
know that she had her tongue cut out so
that she couldn't speak up against the
Lord's either way what appears to be
this
same character is here in the grave of
saints a place that existed way before
the current king of this land I don't
know much about red fountains and Dark
Souls lore in Demon Souls they had an
explanation you know when you died in
spirit form you came back as a hostile
red phantom but in the Dark Souls
universe I guess the only way to see
them is as hostile spirits or something
like that moving on from that fairly
indigestible piece of law let's talk
about the gutter in general I love this
area
so it's frequently referred to as the
place where everything unwanted or
tossed away ends up and honestly this
was my favorite area on my first
playthrough it's the first and I reckon
the only area to make use of the
lighting system and just coming down
here with a torch to help you see and
seeing the massive trash flowing down
towards the bottom it really conveyed
this powerful theme of things being
thrown away and things that would never
see the surface again and this is really
enforced by this one moment where you
drop through a roof into what could
actually be called a living area you see
rugs pots furniture it's all these
things that man would put around to make
it more homely and so all of a sudden
this family of hollows has you crashed
down into this home that they'd made for
themselves and it's this tiny brief
glimpse of humanity in a place that's
notoriously devoid of it and you crash
through and the hollows defend their
home and you cut them all down without a
second thought
because this is dark souls and you kill
whatever's in front of you and I had
just been startled as I crushed through
here and I didn't take in my
surroundings I just wanted to survive I
killed everything that came at me and
then in the aftermath I thought and
maybe you did too that the little homely
Touches of this area were significant
because sometimes we're not really the
good guy in this game you know and this
brief experience started to form the
foundations of what I think about the
gutter in general I like to think that
all the humans down here you know
however they ended up here whether there
were just hollowed corpse thrown down
here so they wouldn't be seen again I
just think that maybe they were trying
to build their way out with this wooden
structure or something like that and
this thought even though it's not
confirmed you know
it's just a brief thought that I had it
really gave more weight to this area for
me another being in the gutter is the
giant ant queen the guide suggests that
it began its life in lord aldia z'
laboratory and it eventually lived its
usefulness it lays here passive dosel
away from its natural habitat and
discarded like everything else in the
gutter if you got poisoned by those
little poisonous ticks that guard it
then maybe you noticed that it actually
cures poison and I really appreciate
that they made it passive and looking
away from you like that you know you're
initially startled you don't expect to
see it but then you really start to feel
a little bit of pity for this misplaced
creature and then there are these
statues put around the place Gilligan
reckons that there might be the remnants
of some pagan cult but there is no real
explanation for them one theory I read
online is that they represent the
Emerald Herald they look a fair bit like
ER with the hood and the way they're
posed the fact that there's hundreds of
them could make you think that they were
created to honor someone but honestly in
my opinion I think they might have been
created as more of an obsession than to
honor someone there's one of them being
hung within the gutter which is this
really grim image and there's another
thing I came up with you also have to
consider that they spit poison which
could be fairly metaphorical for
spitting lies you know vitriol if it
does represent the herald then perhaps
someone created them out of spite we
know one character at least who thinks
that the words of the Emerald Herald are
a bunch of nonsense they say that she is
the last fire keeper but they say a lot
of things that she's a gentle shepherd
lighting the way for you cursed fools
nonsense and finally we get to the
rotten who we disturb as he attempts to
fix one of the statues is he responsible
for them is this his obsession is this
where he gets his happiness from maybe
he's upset because we're the ones going
through cutting all their heads off in
new game+ you realize that he has the
soul of the old dead one which was neato
in Dark Souls 1 just like neato he
aggravates things to him to create a
hole but the
cotton is a bit more intriguing to me
when you wait outside his fog gate you
can actually hear him crying from
outside and I assume that this was all
the tortured souls that were fused to
him when you cut off his left hand he
drops a Pharaoh's lock stone which has
led a lot of people to believe that he
might be pharaohs known for creating
traps and may be responsible for
creating the statues but ultimately what
do you think you make your own story in
the gutter and that's kind of what I
wanted to get out with this video it's a
good example of how the story can branch
and most of the ideas that you read in
the comment section I reckon they'll be
pretty valid but if you're looking for
more solid interpretations of the law
then check out my video I did recently
on the overall story of Dark Souls 2 the
story of the king and the queen is my
favorite in a souls game so far and I
think that you'll understand why if you
watch that video if you're looking for
more videos like these though then
you're going to be in luck because I
think the next few weeks I'm going to
devote to exploring the rest of
drangleic through story mode and through
10 things you missed so that we can get
a good understanding of the world before
we start going a bit more in-depth into
each individual character as usual
though thank you so much for watching
and supporting and liking all these
videos as this channel grows I feel like
I can't necessarily respond to each
individual one of you like I might have
used to but rest assured I do read the
vast majority of your comments I just
don't at the time to reply to them all
and I really am proud of the mature
fanbase I have compared to some other
people my youtube comment section is way
better than a lot of others on YouTube
and I can really respect you all for
that so thanks guys really if you like
you can become a part of the small group
that Kindles this channel by clicking on
the bonfire so feel free to click and
figure out what that's all about but
ultimately I appreciate every single one
of you watching and other than that I'll
see you in the next one later guys